that's what's up man um talk about like
the whole funk volume thing man i mean i
know most people um who are probably
watching this are fans of yours but
there's gonna be some people that are
that that are um you know kind of maybe
have heard about you and checking it out
um what is it like man being on a roster
with like a guy like jared benton and
and hops and everybody's been on the
freshman cover three years in a row yeah
a nice little run right now yeah we yeah
we got three artists from the double xl
freshman and the cover and it's dope man
just because everybody's different um
but everybody wants to be everybody
always wants to do better you know and
um
we kind of push each other to go hard
you know just kind of like not even just
pushing each other like in each other
ear but you know we all see each other
grinding we all want to work as hard as
as our label mates and like we have
family now so we just want to keep up
with each other so it's pretty dope but
the best thing about funk volume man is
our shows
we got the live shows like we put on
great shows we rapping every word we
energize we you know the fan the fans is
into it we into it we sweating
you know we standing on the crowd
smoking on the crowd so it's just like
we really built our our our [__] around
our shows the live show for real and i
saw that the uh the independent living
documentary
is it debuting on revolt or already oh
yeah it already did um what like two
days ago i think
like did you notice any like increase in
cats hitting you up on twitter or yeah
yeah that was i i seen a lot of people
hit me up man cause i threw up on myself
in the movie
and i seen a lot of people hitting me up
telling me yeah he threw up on his shelf
he's out of shape 2012 show right yeah
that was that was your was that your
first fun volume tour
yeah that was the first funk volume tour
i had did a tour earlier than that the
smoke out conversation store that's
crazy mm-hmm
that was just from being out of shape
i actually was racing yeah yeah yeah
i remember when i used to be a
basketball practice have to run them
suicides man they end up throwing up
yeah nah i had raced um hopsin and and i
had liquor in my system too but you know
that doesn't help it didn't you know i
thought i could beat the [__] and we
raced twice the second time is what
[__] me up
and um yeah i threw up on myself that's
what's up man who are um some artists
that like uh have reached out to you man
because i feel like every time i see you
you're kind of like in a different space
as far as you know how big you're
getting how big your buzz is like who
are are some um
some artists that you admire that have
like recently reached out and given you
like a you know a salute or you know
maybe let you know that they're aware of
you and and are fans of what you're
doing
um
snoop dogg just hit me up he live in
vegas now oh he does um yeah he live out
there now because his his son goes to
school out there
um where's the sun go bishop gorman yeah
oh see i don't know
you know
they'd be recruiting but um
yeah he reached out he always showing
love um
i'm actually going to get together with
mac miller we're going to do some stuff
we're going to work it out yeah i ran
into mac miller at the um airport and
you know he was letting me know that he
had some beats and some stuff so
hopefully we can still work it out
and um
a few cats i'm always running into
people man casey veggies he always show
love i always show love the veggies
yeah isaiah rashad oh okay that'd be
dope yeah he um
he's okay
that's the homie he's a character yeah
um i mean snoop man being in vegas y'all
gotta make that happen oh yeah
definitely yeah as soon as he let me
know i was like oh sh oh [__] we got a
smoke you gotta have like a welcome to
vegas party work yeah yeah everything
you gotta yo there's some random rappers
that live in vegas like dj paul you
always go out and see dj paul random
really dj paul from three six mafia that
fool's always i seen him turnt up at
south by southwest oh you crunchy black
living in vegas too
it makes sense
you'll go out to crown nightclub i know
it's closed down but i remember you see
the crunchy black and gary payton
kicking it to get like the most
randomized
yeah because gary payton's son go to
school out there yeah
that's what's up man so dizzy uh we can
expect a new album
yeah
soon man soon i'm coming i'm gonna be
dropping music though i'm still going
you know me i know you just put out an
ep with bishop neru yeah uh
and knife wonder yeah and um it didn't
let the fans seem to like it i like it
you told me it came it came to be kind
of weird yeah it was it was fast it was
a fast process but uh like i would have
liked to take more time with it with
bishop like we could have really you
know
made something real nice out of it but
it came together cool getting together
real cool if there was someone else that
like uh maybe like a new new cat that
that you you're real tight with someone
that you you could see yourself doing
like a collaboration little one-off
joint like that with who else would it
be
logic logic see that'd be dope yeah
logic definitely we want to do it too we
just haven't been able to come around to
the time
but um eventually it's going to happen
elijah is the nicest human being in the
world he is doc
he is man he reminds me he he makes me
remember that you know being positive is
the right way to go yeah man
i never met nobody nicer in the end he
reminds me
all the time yeah logic's a dope dude
annie
and he's really one of the hardest
rappers today right yeah
dude he's really one of the freestyle
yeah every day he can do the fast rap
speed it down explain it to you like
he's really one of the hardest right now
right now period you know so but i do
want to we're going to do a project
we're going to do a tour we're going to
do everything yeah
we're going to do everything turn it